So is English mania good or bad?
Is English a tsunami, washing away other languages?
Not likely.
English is the world's second language.
Your native language is your life.
But with English you can become part of a wider conversation.
A global conversation about global problems.
Like climate change or poverty, or hunger, or disease.
The world has other universal languages.
Mathematics is the language of science.
Music is the language of emotions.
And now English is becoming the language of problem solving.
Not because America is pushing it.
But because the world is pulling it.
So English mania is a turning point.
Like the harnessing of electricity in our cities or the fall of the Berlin Wall.
English represents hope for a better future.
A future where the world has a common language...
...to solve its common problems.
Thank you very much.